what are you freaking tired of hearing
about seeing talking about
tell me
oh man there's so many things hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today i will be talking to one of your
favorite content creators john from
obese to beast as part of my new series
well fed and fed up
here we will be talking about diet
culture body image mental health and
more
every episode i will be sitting down
with a fellow influencer or content
creator to ask some really tough
questions and have real uncensored
unscripted discussions without the shame
and judgment because we're all a little
fed up right i ain't coming now no more
i'm thinking you're trying to calm me
down now before we dive in i want to
remind you to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with past or current experiences with
disordered eating i also want to remind
you guys to subscribe to the channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on an episode
all right thank you so much for joining
me john i'm really excited to chat with
you here
oh yeah i'm super excited thanks for
having me
um so briefly why don't you just tell me
a little bit about like the thought
process behind your channel in general
uh wow so it started off as just
basically me wanting to make a channel
for people that are trying to lose
weight by someone who has lost weight
because when i started i've been doing
this for eight years now i actually just
realized that and that's way too long
but i've been doing this for eight years
so when i first started youtube there
really wasn't many people doing like hey
this is how you lose weight and i also
have lost weight so that was kind of the
reason that i started the channel and
then over years you know things change
youtube changes and now basically what i
do is more i guess commentary based kind
of similar to what you do right um i
i like to share my opinion i like to
think that i have a pretty neutral
opinion or at least a pretty like
level-headed opinion on things
especially when it comes to fitness and
weight loss and so that's what i do now
okay so i want to talk about what i see
is kind of being almost the focus of
your channel over the past year or so
and that is kind of talking about the
body positive movement now as someone
who's lost a lot of weight and obviously
you know rightfully quite proud of that
and you feel it was important to do that
for your health um it seems like you
know a lot of talk around body
positivity seems to kind of be
triggering for you um do you feel
triggered by like larger body people
promoting body positivity or like health
at every size
no i think that personally for me my
whole stance is that everyone should be
body positive that's kind of how where i
go how i go about things so i guess like
triggered is a word that some people
like some people don't like but i get
bothered when anyone is
policing that term or making it or i
guess gatekeeping is a better word when
people are gatekeeping that term um and
kind of telling people you're you're
allowed to be body positive or you're
not allowed to be body positive that's
that's when i have i guess i have an
issue
totally and so like what are your
thoughts on smaller body folks using
terms like that
for me it doesn't like i think everyone
should use it right like the the term is
and i know that there's there's more
that goes into like why people believe
that you should or shouldn't use it and
all that stuff but like for me the term
is body positive and everyone has a body
and i feel like everyone should be
positive about it um so i don't
my whole thing is like i think everyone
should be able to use it um i know there
are there are different terms now
there's you know there's body positive
there's body neutrality there's body
acceptance and all those have a little
bit different meanings um and i've been
learning about that as well um but i
think all in all all of those terms are
you know should be a positive thing for
for people and like you mentioned
there's a variety of different terms
like what term would you use to describe
yourself and your relationship with your
body right now
yeah that's a great question so i would
say that i mean i've just been diving
into the research and like diving into
the explanations but i recently read an
article where it kind of went over the
three different ones and i would say i
i would probably
identify the most with body acceptance
like my body is you know i accept it
there are days when i'm body positive
but i think that trying claiming that
you're always positive about your body
is just not realistic and it goes into
the whole toxic positivity thing which i
think is an issue as well um but i would
say like body acceptance body neutrality
is a little bit too extreme for me just
kind of being like i don't care about my
body and it doesn't matter i think that
that's that's a really hard ask for a
lot of people so for me i would say body
acceptance is what would like describe
me more i guess yeah that totally makes
sense and you know i've watched a lot of
your videos and it seems you are often
like quite critical of intuitive eating
because you know you feel it's for a
very specific person who has maybe never
struggled with their weight like i know
you have in the past and i do agree that
it's not for everyone and i actually say
this literally in every video where i
mention intuitive eating
i don't necessarily agree that it's like
not for folks who have struggled with
their weight but it's certainly not for
everyone
but i am curious in your mind just
knowing what you do know about intuitive
eating
who is it for and who is it not for
that's a good question i think that
intuitive eating in in general is a
great thing and i i personally believe
um that it should be the end goal for
anyone that's on any sort of like weight
loss journey or just health journey in
general where food's a big you know
because there are people that never have
issues with food and they don't have to
worry about intuitive eating or anything
like that right in my opinion but people
that have had food struggles whether
that's eating too little eating too much
or anything in between
i think that getting to that point where
you're no longer tracking is that is the
goal
but for me i'm critical of people just
kind of claiming that if you have
struggles with food just start doing
intuitive eating and then you will be
healed i think that that's a little a
little uh narrow-minded and
i think that we should more talk about
how do we get to a point where we are
doing intuitive eating and i know that
you've probably seen me say like i don't
like to say what i do is intuitive
eating i like to call it like mindful
eating um there's not that much of a
difference to be honest but like i the
the main difference i guess is that i
still use some of the tools that i
learned through tracking um to make i
try to make smart decisions in the food
that i eat but i haven't like tracked my
macros in five or six years um and so
that's why that's why i call what i do
mindful eating it's very similar to
intuitive eating but honestly like the
whole intuitive eating thing it's it's
become kind of
it's just become so toxic in in
different culture or in different
circles that i try and stay away from it
really yeah i i understand you're saying
i mean a lot of people get feel very
triggered when
um intuitive eating is used for you know
weight loss or weight loss circles or
things like that simply because the
concept as it was originally
conceptualized by its creators was not
for weight loss ultimately you know
intuitive eating is not for everyone um
it definitely you know some people who
are in larger bodies and trying to lose
weight may lose weight when they take on
intuitive eating they can um but like i
said it's definitely not a technique for
everyone right at the gates nor is it a
quick fix nor is it something that you
know i would recommend if your goal is
to lose weight
and i do want to say this though because
it's something that's important to me
because i think that there are a lot of
people that might have similar beliefs
that i have that take it too far this is
this is with everything in the world but
um
it frustrates me when i hear the uh the
term well i intuitively ate myself into
xyz 300 pounds whatever it is right
that's frustrating to me because i think
that that's that's almost straw manning
and turning it into something that it's
not i think that intuitive eating or
mindful eating whatever you want to call
it you know trying to be smart with your
nutrition without actually tracking
everything i think that it's a beautiful
thing and it can help
incredible amount of people um but again
it's not it's not a silver bullet that's
going to solve all the problems for
everybody but i don't think that it's a
negative thing and i think people have
turned it that that maybe don't agree
with it fully have turned into a
negative thing which i think is
just isn't helpful i totally agree and
and when i hear a statement like what
you just suggested that i you know i
intuitively ate myself into obesity or
whatever um i intuitively ate um x y and
z i think that
they're not quite understanding the
breadth of the intuitive eating movement
because i think most people when they
say or hear intuitive eating they're
only thinking
i eat when i'm hungry i eat whatever i
want and i stop eating you know when i'm
not hungry anymore
um but that's just like one component of
intuitive eating so i think it really
just comes back down to not
understanding the movement um in its you
know
in its full how it was fully
conceptualized and that actually
includes gentle nutrition the gentle
nutrition is actually built in and i i
agree 100 and that's why i think because
there are so many people that have that
uh
kind of preconceived notion for me
instead of trying to change their mind
and switch exactly how they think that's
why i like to say i what i do is mindful
eating and like what's that and
basically i'm like it's basically like
me with a trojan horse that's like
mindful eating and then inside of it is
actually intuitive eating which is like
a little bit of changes it's really not
that different but people because they
hear intuitively like oh my god no i've
heard so much bad things about that but
then i tell them mindfully and they're
like interesting
yeah yeah no i i totally get it and um
and speaking of intuitive eating i know
like one of the criticisms i've heard
from you in some of your videos
about intuitive eating is this idea that
you know you let yourself eat the
forbidden food that eventually you won't
want it anymore this is something that
you hear from a lot of haze or intuitive
eating proponents
and it seems like maybe that wasn't the
case for you and your experience when
you were obese which i think is totally
fair so i i'm curious like why do you
think that you wanted like mcdonald's or
junk food so often so much
um like was it a habit was it that it
tasted really good do you think you were
addicted to it or was it just that maybe
you weren't like in a really good it
really good tune with your body like you
didn't have a good sense of what felt
good to your body
yeah this is that's a great question as
well i think that
the reason i hate when or i don't want
to say hate but the reason i i dislike
when people say if you just allow
yourself to eat it and take away the
guilt right you'll all of a sudden feel
fine and you'll you'll be able to
control it i think that again i'm not
going to say that that doesn't work for
anyone i'm sure that it can but i don't
like when people use kind of absolutist
language on anything saying like if you
do this this is what will happen because
it worked for you this is a whole
criticism i have against a lot of things
on the internet people
use their experience as this is the
end-all be-all and it's like that worked
for you that's great but that doesn't
mean it's gonna work for everyone but um
when it when it comes along when it
comes to like with me and like eating
you know mcdonald's and and mexican food
i live in san diego so it's really
popular here and all that stuff like
there was no
like there was no guilt about it i
didn't feel bad it was just i for me a
big thing that i talk a lot about on my
channel is about teaching yourself about
nutrition right now you don't have to
become an expert but like understanding
you know the calories that are in these
these foods and like why maybe drinking
a like for me a two liter of soda every
day isn't the best idea right like
learning those little things really made
me realize okay this is why i'm gaining
the weight it's not just by happenstance
and like i'm just unlucky because i used
to really think that like i used to joke
around and say oh i don't have a
metabolism with my friends because
they'd be eating mcdonald's and in my
head i'm like why aren't they gaining
weight but looking back i was eating
literally three times as much as they
were right
and so for me i think that it's not as
simple as just taking away the guilt
because i didn't have any guilt eating
mcdonald's every day i just didn't care
i didn't know anything i didn't know any
better right um and so that's why i'm
kind of critical about that that point
when i when i hear like
haze or whatever people kind of talking
about that
i'm just curious when when that you know
in that stage of your life when you were
consistently having mcdonald's or
you know fried foods or things like that
every day like how did you feel like
physically
i wasn't living i was just existing like
that's what i've said that a million
times on my channel and i truly felt
that way you know and i i understand
that not everyone has that same exact
experience i get it and like that's why
i don't tell people what they need to do
but if you are feeling that way
i don't think that you're a bad person
for feeling that way and if you want to
maybe make a change you can that's kind
of the you know that's the premise on
most of my videos at least yeah and i
mean i think that that's a really great
mantra and message to put out there um
and and you know even though i don't
really have a weight loss channel so to
speak um i often like a lot of my
followers actually you know might be
want to gain weight or get out of weight
loss mentality um but i do think that i
believe in like body autonomy and i
always say this that i don't judge you
if you want to lose weight i'm not you
know i'm not one of those dietitians i'm
trying to learn to not be one of those
dietitians that insist that you know or
or or makes it seem like if you want to
lose weight that you're failing or that
you must have low self-esteem i think
everyone has the right to want to change
their body in whatever way they want for
whatever reason they want whether it's
for health reasons or aesthetic reasons
any reason is valid in my books
i'm not here to judge that and i think
it only makes sense that in our
aesthetic driven society that we do just
naturally want to change our body or
look our best and feel our best and
there shouldn't be any additional guilt
and shame associated with that so
yeah i think that that's a really great
message to be putting out there
now i did see in a recent video of yours
you talked about when you started your
weight loss journey you like restricted
your calories so heavily that it
actually caused binging so it seems like
there is actually some evidence there um
from your own experience that you know
dieting too hard or too aggressively can
do harm
so i'm curious i mean i know you don't
use the term intuitive eating for
yourself now but do you think that some
of the principles of intuitive eating
would have been helpful for you back
when you know you were struggling at
your your your highest weights there
um i think that
they they could have been helpful
i
like my whole my whole kind of journey
when it comes to losing weight was i
started off obviously eating whatever i
wanted like i didn't know anything about
nutrition and then i started what i call
the common sense diet so it was like
cutting out soda junk food and like fast
food which was uh a lot of what i was
eating at the time and i really like
i've explained this a lot but like i
really think that the way i started was
like a relatively healthy way to do it
right just like cutting out the foods
that regardless of how much you know
about nutrition are probably not the
best for you to be eating right and i
know that that can be argued against but
like for someone that was my size it
seemed like a good thing to do but then
over time i just kind of i started to
learn a little bit about calories and i
understood what they were but then it
got bad because then i started thinking
okay calories are the enemy and so i
need to reduce them as much as i
possibly can um and that's when it
started getting bad right that's when i
started eating you know to a point there
was at one point i was eating like 700
calories a day and i was like why am i
not like i would do that for three days
and then i would overeat for one of the
days which now i realized was binging
but i didn't realize what i was doing at
the time
um and so that's when it got bad and so
i think that just
honestly having any more knowledge about
what i was doing at that time would have
been helpful but i just i didn't have it
right i just kind of started and i was
doing it on the fly and i was trying to
figure it out myself um i think that you
know having those especially with what
you talk about like intuitive eating
with like the gentle nutrition could
have been helpful for me like having
some guidelines at least
um but i mean that's why
that's why i'm so
i'm so adamant on my channel and i'm
sure you've seen this in videos is i
whenever i see these fad diets whenever
i see these really extreme things i
always say they will work 100 they'll
get you to lose weight real quick but is
that the goal
i don't think so right the goal is to
lose weight but more importantly be
healthy for the rest of your life period
right that's what we should be doing and
these really extreme diets the reason i
have such a like a visceral reaction is
because i see myself doing that i mean
maybe i wasn't doing any particular diet
but i was way going way too hard and i'd
know where that led me and i don't want
people to go down that road
and so that's why i am a fan of you know
learning how to track your macros
learning how to do those things but not
relying on them forever and finding
intuitive eating mindful eating whatever
you know whatever you want to call it
yeah for sure and and speaking of your
past experience with restricting and
binging
do you feel like you have like a
completely normal relationship with food
today
that's a really good question i
i personally believe that i do
as much as you can dealing with what
i've dealt with like i i i only know how
my relationship with food has ever been
so like maybe it's not perfect but i've
never been in someone else's body that
maybe has never had food issues right so
it's hard for me to really know if it's
like 100 normal
but i will say the the thing that makes
me feel like i definitely am in a good
spot at least is that i have zero and i
mean that zero fear that i will ever go
back to being the size that i was and
when i was struggling with food and when
i was struggling with binge eating i was
terrified because i felt like i was
holding on by a thread and it was like
any little thing could push me over the
edge right could cut that thread and
then i'd be back to where i was
now because of how much i know about
nutrition and all the things that i've
learned
it would be it would be a it would be
very hard for me to do that like i would
have to completely stop doing the things
that i enjoy and completely change the
way i'm eating now to end up there so i
would say i think i have about as
healthy of a relationship with food as
you can with someone that has had the
past that i've had if that makes sense
yeah no it totally does and and do you
ever find yourself like slipping into
some of like the more problematic
behaviors that you had dealt with in the
past
i would say the
the one thing that i have dealt with the
most is kind of doing like food hoarding
like or like macro hoarding or calorie
hoarding for the end of the day
i've gotten better over time especially
now that like i'm currently training for
a triathlon so i'm doing lots of
training sessions and i need to fuel
those sessions so i can't do that um but
like that was that has been and
definitely was the hardest thing for me
particularly to break because i like
going to bed with the full stomach i
like i mean i remember when you did um
you did your review on my diet you said
like you know he should like you said it
would have been smart to maybe have a
snack here so you weren't so hungry when
you had dinner like that's something
that i have i definitely have dealt with
for sure and you know it's funny you say
that because obviously we come from
different places um but i actually when
i was struggling with disordered eating
i also definitely did the food hoarding
towards the end of the day i think it's
quite common and i think you know a lot
of us have that um delayed gratification
um thing going on where you know we're
able to hold ourselves hold ourselves
hold ourselves in that state of hunger
in a little bit and then by the end of
the day like you said like we don't like
to go to bed hungry we kind of like save
at all so it's something to look forward
to at the end of the day it's almost
like having almost like a cheat it's the
cheat meal mentality but condensed to
each little day so to speak um i
actually think it's quite common for
folks who have chronically dieted so
you're not alone there
okay so speaking of dieting i'm curious
uh are there any like diet rules that
you still stick to pretty strictly
nothing super crazy i tried to just be
smart
i try not to eat things that are super
calorically dense all the time for no
reason
if i'm like at someone's birthday party
i'm gonna have cake i'm not gonna say no
i still try and be smart about my liquid
calories because it's just so easy to go
over on those right like i used to be a
huge soda drinker i don't drink soda i
have diet sodas and some people freak
out when you talk about that but um you
know there are like little things that i
do i would say like the liquid calories
is still one that like for me unless
it's like a nice coffee drink because i
can't drink black coffee and whoever
does is a psychopath in my opinion but
you know it is fine um but like other
than that that's pretty much that would
i would say that's like the biggest rule
that i've i've stuck to is just avoiding
liquid calories especially if there are
better options that don't have any
calories yeah no i honestly i actually
just released a kind of um a video on
weight loss tips believe it or not which
is i know out of out of um out of my
kind of normal comfort zone but of
course these are things that i get asked
about and things that i also know about
um and actually that is one of my tips
is that you know it's actually very hard
to regulate our hunger and fullness when
it comes to those liquid calories so
unlike food where i think even if you
are practicing intuitive eating the
research shows that you know we don't
really self-regulate those calories from
liquids like we do from food even if you
have like a really strong relationship
with food and you're really in tune with
your body and your hunger and fullness
it is very easy to just
you know down an extra 500 calories when
you are having juice or soda or alcohol
of course um or any kind of more calorie
filled drink so i'm i'm totally on on
board with that in my opinion i also
don't drink a lot of my calories as well
just not as satisfying of course as
chewing that food
yeah i agree
um now you mentioned and we've talked
about this briefly but you mentioned
that you had learned enough
about nutrition through tracking to be
able to engage in that kind of more
mindful eating um so can you just like
briefly tell me i know mindful eating to
you is like intuitive eating but i'm
curious what about the tracking helps
you get to that place
yeah so learning learning how to track
macros and calories really it just
showed me
how some foods are just so unbelievably
dense in calories um you know like
cheesecake or just things that have
maybe like a lot of fat that maybe you
didn't realize or the amount of calories
that are in some beverages and just
things like that right so learning all
of those things and then also just kind
of having similar foods i'm someone that
i eat similar foods all the time it's
it's a thing that people joke around
with me about i eat stir fry all the
time i really enjoy it right i eat
oatmeal all the time i really enjoy it
people make fun of me it's a great time
um but like so being able to know like
if i eat this is probably going to be
around this many calories and it's it's
not even i don't even have to really
think about it all of those little
things
have played a part in how i look at food
now right and how i make i i try to make
smart decisions and that can be
different for everyone but smart
decisions for me
and and you know fuel my body for the
workouts that i'm doing and for the life
that i'm trying to live and so that
that's how it's it's kind of helped me
um it's it's just given me tools to make
better decisions i guess
and you mentioned you eat a lot of the
same kinds of foods every day and you
have a sense okay this probably has like
this only a bowl probably has like 350
calories i mean i'm a dietitian so if i
turn that part of my brain on i could
also calorie count these things too all
day long if i wanted to but i'm just
curious what do you think would happen
if you
ate foods different foods for a week
that maybe you weren't weren't already
ingrained in your head the macros the
calories all the numbers what do you
think would happen to your body to your
weight
that's a good question i think that
i would definitely
i would definitely be a little anxious
because like for me i i i have anxiety
and stuff and so part of why and also
add i'm not i'm not trying to go on all
that stuff but like part of the reason
why i eat similar foods is because of
those things
so like i know that i would definitely
probably feel pretty anxious um i do i
think that i would gain a substantial
amount of weight not really i went to
the uk
years back and this was years after i
had been done tracking and obviously i
wasn't able to eat the similar foods
that i ate and i was there for two
months and i didn't come back like way
heavier or way lighter so i was like
able to just kind of try and be smart so
i think that i would be able to do it
it's just why would i want to put myself
through that like something that i see a
lot on youtube is like food challenges i
do not enjoy them um because like at
least for me like i i would never want
to do one and like film it and put it on
youtube just because i feel like that's
kind of putting a bad message out there
right and so like i think that it would
definitely make me anxious for sure but
i think that i would it wouldn't be like
that that big of a deal if that makes
sense and then also i i feel like
because i'm my body is so used to eating
similar things that my body might be
like what is going on here
yeah i also don't do the food challenge
thing i
couldn't i just don't think i would i
would enjoy it also i would wanna i have
a family so it's like do i really want
to put my family on keto for a week hell
no
um so yeah i i just don't think that uh
i don't i don't find myself enjoying
those watching those videos either i
just
i don't know not a concept that that um
that i can relate to so you mentioned
that you have anxiety and i mean i have
anxiety i would say that most content
creators that i've spoken to have
anxiety
um and this is not an easy
profession this is not an easy space to
to be in
um i'm curious like how do you deal as
somebody with anxiety uh with backlash
with negative comments with people other
people making videos about you with just
just the negativity the trolling that
happens on youtube
please let me learn from you
uh not well is how i deal with it no um
i just again like for me what i try and
do and i i really believe this i think
if if i truly believe what i said in a
video and i stand behind it a hundred
percent if there is backlash that's okay
right and that that can happen and it
does happen but if i truly believe what
i stand if i truly stand behind what i
said and i believe in every word then
then i'm fine but i also am willing and
you know in this past year and a half
two years
my stances on a lot of stuff have
shifted and changed because i have
learned more about stuff and so i think
that that for me that's what really
helps a lot is like i truly when i put
out a video i truly believe
and i stand behind everything i say um
and if eventually my mind change changes
or i have you know i have that shift i
don't mind you know saying that and i
think for a lot of people
a lot of the anxiety comes from what if
i'm wrong but i and you feel like you
can't change your mind about it because
you have this hard stance so that that's
for me really is what helps is just
knowing that i i believe what i'm saying
in the moment and if i end up changing
my mind i don't mind you know being like
hey i changed my mind
i think that's great advice and
something that i do myself i mean you've
seen my metamorphosis over uh the years
and that you know i've i've just been
learning myself and bringing people
along with me on that learning journey
and and so it's i think a really
important
um it's really important for
professionals to
to change as they learn and as new
evidence comes out and that they change
their stance on certain things um so
that's only natural i'm human i'm not a
robot and so as i learn more i adapt my
my my position and uh and so it's been
it's been nice to bring people on that
journey and i know i'm gonna lose people
the same way if i was like if i was
vegan and then i went on vegan you're
gonna expect that some people are going
to be pissed about it and they're not
going to want to follow you anymore but
i think that that you know there's no
point in you putting out messages if you
don't believe them yourself and i think
it's really important to be true to
yourself and to be honest when your
stance on something has changed when
you're wrong about something i try to be
transparent when i am wrong about
something when i just don't know because
i'm not you know we're not experts on
everything so yeah i think that that's
all really good advice
take a note
and speaking of like the wellness
community i'm curious what are you
super fed up with in this community like
what are you freaking tired of hearing
about seeing talking about
tell me
oh man there's so many things um
it's it's really the extremes on both
ends so the extremes on maybe like
health at every size or whatever you
want to call it and then the extremes of
like fitness i just
like when you see the waist trainers and
the fit tees and like
i am sick
this is this truly is what it comes down
to i am sick of influencers
using people's insecurities to make
money for themselves
whether that's on this side of the
spectrum or on this side of the spectrum
that's what i'm sick of of using
people's insecurities to make money for
themselves there's nothing wrong with
making money and like you know having
followers and that being a way to make
money totally fine i get it like hello
you know but if you are preying on
people's insecurities and that's how
you're making your money uh it bothers
me and i might make a video about it
yeah i totally agree and like you said
there's so much of it and no one's
immune like no matter what kind of
content you're gravitating towards
you're going to be fed
some kind of obnoxious sales pitch
so and and very likely from somebody who
actually has no qualifications or no
business giving you said sales pitch
so yeah i i see it too and i totally
agree that it's it's a problem
um and i don't and and i think people
are going to have a hard time
kind of shielding themselves from that
information uh just because social media
is so toxic
yeah it's tough man like it's
they're
it's definitely something i've noticed
is
there's been this weird i don't want to
say shift but a lot of people they'll
see someone that has a lot of followers
and they'll just kind of
assume that they're correct and i think
that's very dangerous
i think it's very dangerous i think like
with anything always be an inform like i
made a whole post about this but always
be informed like
influencers aren't your friends and i
don't mean that in a negative way but
just understand like the recommendation
you would get from a friend is very
different from the recommendation you
would get from an influencer especially
if there is they are somehow getting
paid and making money off of this
recommendation so just be careful be
informed be a smart consumer
yeah i 100 agree
and on that note i mean what do you want
my community to know about your message
and you know who your content is for who
your content is not for um what do they
need to know if they have not watched an
obese to beast video before yeah
uh good question i would say if you've
seen the thumbnails and you're like i
won't like his videos maybe watch one
because normally they're pretty much
clickbait but you know it is what it is
it's youtube um but like for me the the
message that i want to put out there is
that if you want to lose weight that's
very important if you want to lose
weight
i believe that you can do that and i
believe there is a way to do that that
is healthy that doesn't have to be
extreme that won't make you feel like
absolute garbage that you can sustain
for the rest of your life if you don't
want to lose weight that's totally fine
and then on top of that if you are
making content preying on other people
or or selling lies or you know just
telling lies
i might make a video about that as well
so i guess that would be the uh the the
message is i i truly believe that i'm
doing what i can to help as many people
as possible without trying to steal or
take advantage of people as well
that's so great that was so interesting
john i learned so much i'm sure my
audience learned so much and um if they
haven't already checked out your channel
obese to beast i'm going to leave some
information of course in the description
so that you know where to find
john
but thank you so much john for joining
me
no yeah this was great i had a ton of
fun talking and maybe we'll do it again
soon sometimes absolutely
and folks that is all that i have for
you guys today if you loved this video
don't forget to give me the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me interview next for my fed
up series subscribe to the channel and i
will see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you